17th major league start for mitch keller
fourth career start against the st louis
cardinals that pitch taken low and it's
a lead off walk for tommy edmonds and
here is nolan ornato on the home stand
went four for 34.
and he yanks that down the left field
line it is well hit and gone
off the foul pole down the left field
line
and a two nothing first inning lead with
one swing of the bat by nolan orinato
home run number 26. and it's miles
michaelis ricky and keel going tonight
oh and control
had been mikeless's calling card
and he walks the first battery faces in
the bottom of the first
swing and a miss and a strikeout for
miles michaelis
brings in brian reynolds
oh what a play here edmond flips it the
turn
not in time but what a play tommy edmond
goodness what a play here with the shift
on tommy edmond
wow
if i'm reynolds i'm already counting
that as a base hit when it comes off the
bat
only to dive but then the backhand on a
short hop full on laid out what a play
the one-two
swing and a miss tied them up and a
strikeout two in the inning for miles
michaelis this bar is on for edmundo
sosa
up the middle base hit sosa newt bart is
second and he'll stop there back in
safely and the first two have reached
here in the top of the second for the
cardinals
michaelis pushes it fair to moran
runners advance to second and third
anna brings in tommy edmonds the cow
runs full
and that is pulled
bare down into the corner two runs will
score
edmond on his way to second base
with the double as he drives in a pair
and it's four-nothing cardinals here in
inning number two
so four-nothing lead for the cardinals
edmund at second and now paul
goldschmidt
goldschmidt base head into left
edmond being waved in no throw by gamble
and that'll make it a five-nothing st
louis lead rbi number 74 for paul
goldsmith here's gregory polanco
that's hit hard to right field
gregory polanco into second base with a
double
yeah great situation now to get those
at least a couple of those runs back
defo at third polanco trails at second
nobody out the one one for michaelis
swinging a ground ball on the short
that'll score the run
sources throw to first they get the out
rbi bounce out bringing in defoe it's
five to one here's yadier molina and
there's a base hit into right i think
what's amazing rick is that since he
became the catcher and in that time
frame the cardinals third best winning
percentage in those 18 years mundo sosa
has singled and scored in the second
inning he bats with two outs
sosa
he knew it a drive right center gone
oh did he know it how about the power
there
mundo sosa two for two tonight his
fourth home run and a two run shot to
put the birds on top 7-1
swinging a lighter into left-base hit
for chavis out of the box hard but it'll
be held to a single here with one out in
the third inning here's the pitch
swinging a fly ball hit to deep right
field and moran has just socked one out
of here
colin moran with a two-run home run to
right
[Applause]
now make it 7-3
home run number seven one ball two
strikes
that should be two
uh newman with a little flash
and
chavis's throw a little wide but no
problem for moran two outs michael
chavis little shovel and then with the
runner coming in carlson with a nice
slide chavis yanked his throw a little
bit calamarin did a really nice job of
keeping his foot on the bag to finish
that double play one two count on chavis
leading off the pirates half of the
fifth
that's fair
chavis has a double
well he's showing life in that bat since
joining the pirates
michael chavez two more hits
and there's another line drive into
center and chavis had to get back to
second
another hard hit ball you'd have to
think that was 95
or better good base running by chavis
who were talking about him being a
little more careful out there two of
eight inherited runners have scored
against mcfarland this season ground
ball double play there's your sinker
there's your ground ball there's your
double play nice work t.j mcfarland the
ground ball hit to sosa turned by edmond
over to goldie it's 7-3 kyle keller
coming on for the second night in a row
he pitched yesterday with an inning
against arizona
that's a line drive to wright and
polanco
oh kyle keller replaces mitch and gets
the last two outs
andrew miller third pitcher used by st
louis tonight o2 pitch got another one
goodbye the strikeout for miller
there it is again and goodbye
thank you very much scoreless inning for
andrew miller
slider after slider after schleider
first at battle of the night for key
brian hayes
lines this to right center field another
hard hit oh it's so hard
and carlson a desperate dive to cut it
off but ends up being a double for hayes
davis two for three against miles
michaelis
goes the other way and drops it into
right field
to load them up we're liking michael
chavis about now ace is loaded with
buckos for brian reynolds
ground ball and how about a little
broken bat bingle to score two
seven five pirates are back in it here's
moran now left on left
oh a soft serve in the right field for
colin moran
and they are loaded how about that
all the hard hit balls all night and we
have two of the softest hits back to
back they're loaded again
[Applause]
line drive banks hitting the left center
field this is gonna tie the game
wilmer defoe d-i-f-o
the pirates have come storming back
against the cardinals
the pirates begin this seventh inning
with six straight hits
and he rips us into left center field
gregory polanco's going to give the
bucks the lead stays in play here comes
defo he will score
what an inning and what a moment for el
cafe
yoshi tsutsugo pinch hitting now for
cool
and so tsugo lines one to deep right
center field and clear the deck with a
cannonball
suit suit tsugio
that is three pinch hit homers what a
week before tsutsugo yeah in a week his
fourth as a pirate how about this blitz
the pirates have put on the cardinals
and coming on the pitch the ninth here
comes david bednar
one-two pitch drive to right center
field reynolds is over and raised the
jolly roger
what a comeback for the pittsburgh
pirates tonight
you